[Music]
bras get advertised for us well-blessed
ladies all the time so many ads so much
disappointment bras are stupidly
expensive and it's become so easy to
exploit us via online ads
the online ads part is especially
insidious because they learn
what we like
algorithms right and then they can see
how long our eyes are on a particular
product
danny i'm sure you're seeing this right
now with you're reading that book the
every and it is terrifying it's so
dystopian because it's 98
utopian
right and so like it seems great oh
they're tailoring ads to me
that sounds better than oh i don't want
another you know ambulance chaser ad or
whatever yeah but
the reason it's more insidious is
because the ambulance chaser ad never
really affected me right right it didn't
compel me to want to buy it but the
instagram ads i'm like oh maybe i would
be happier if i bought this cardigan
maybe i would be happier if i
bought this pair of pants maybe i would
be happier with that t-shirt and then
when we started upgrading our studio
equipment and peter sent me an email
about the new task scam that we have the
the mixing board that's over there you
know we look so professional
that thing's not even on
and now all of a sudden now
anytime i go to a website it's like
sweetwater is advertising task scams to
me i already own it right and but
instagram knows if you've made the
purchase if you've made the clicks we
will feed more and more and more to you
here's some accessories for your new
switchboard here's why you are
inadequate my goodness and you can
become adequate you can become
significant and other people will
approve of you
if you buy this and you buy it now oh
and by the way if you can't afford it
ryan it's just four easy payments for
that t-shirt you can finance it you can
finance a bra now and you know what i'm
not buying any more bros i'm done
bravo
did you enjoy this stand-alone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free
you